[Music]
[Applause]
Jason Jackson Jr III Miami Heat
play-by-play voice what were you
expecting last night in Boston with your
Miami Heat oh my father's rolling in his
grave right now this is so sad uh listen
of the 19 Seasons that I've covered this
team this is the most one-off experience
that I've ever had in the sense of
here's a team that just missed the NBA
Finals by a Jimmy Butler missed three I
mean this is far off to the right yeah
that was it and the entire team for the
most part outside of PJ Tucker was
brought back and so you assume the very
least somewhere between one through four
like you're just taking consideration
other teams are going to be better other
teams are not there's going to be some
shifting that's probably about it
and then a yard seven and Omar year
seven ankle all the way through uh Jimmy
Butler and management on his body uh
Kyle Lowry playing way too many minutes
early because of the management on
Jimmy's body to everybody having some
sort of time spent out all of a sudden
the Miami Heat is the team that's missed
the most games due to injury which it's
not a headline for the heat because the
heat don't want that to be a headline
but that's a real availability is a
that's a real thing yeah and then some
some bad losses I'll admit that along
the way so I mean just some terrible
home losses here and there but then
as what happens I think with any team
that has that type of chemistry uh the
desire to get back to where they were if
not trying to get beyond that
um it it just got better Dan along the
way and fortunately this team is playing
its best basketball at the right time it
seems didn't win more than three games
in a row all season long yeah and now
it's just rolling okay explain to us who
Jimmy Butler is
can you explain who Jimmy Butler is I've
I've tried to figure it out now in four
years because I'm wondering I'm like is
Jimmy complex
or is it just super simple
all he ever talks about is one guard
somebody it's very Tomball Texas right
very very outside of Houston mentality
we're not going to talk about defensive
schemes we're not going to talk about
rotations I'm not going to prep about
you know help the helper guard somebody
and then on the other end he talks about
playing the right way which we've heard
forever but for him it's not necessarily
a 30 plus Point night it's what ended up
happening as well six guys in double
figures and him looking and feeling out
the defense first
helping out other guys build their
confidence so when you need big shots
late guys aren't being called upon to do
something they're not comfortable doing
and that's how we rather play and he and
Dan he doesn't need us that's the other
thing he can't stand I mean it's not
like this foe lack of desire to get on a
microphone it is a pure I think disdain
for having to do it and that's part of
this era by the way they're going to get
a lot of this going forward as you and I
play the second nine of our of our
careers uh I think more and more because
of social media and guy's ability to
have when you make 40 million dollars a
year you can have some staff and you can
get out whatever you want so if you want
to sell coffee you don't need to come on
The Dan Patrick Show to sell your coffee
but is he a tough guy to play with if
you look at what happened in Philly in
Minnesota in Chicago I mean he's a Hall
of Famer on his fourth team and he plays
at a high level
I just wonder what happened with these
other stops and is that going to happen
in Miami
you can't
be tougher than the experience in Miami
simply because there's just too much
certainty
27 years of Pat Riley as the president
uh 35 years of the same family the
Harrison's owning the team
uh Eric Bolster in his 15th season as
they head coaches in his 27th season
in the organization I have been a
broadcaster for this team for almost 20
years and I'm still not senior you know
so it's yeah there's just way too much
certainty
in the organization everywhere around to
be tougher than what the organization
calls for and I think that's finally a
thriving moment for him I'm looking at
the roster and and there's a great quote
being bad in the NBA is a Choice Talent
is everywhere with the right eye
and that is Pat Riley you got Caleb
Martin undrafted Max struce undrafted
gave Vinson undraft to Duncan Robinson
undrafted you got bam 14th overall Tyler
hero 13th pick Kevin Love on his last
leg Udonis Haslam on the bet I mean
you're you're looking at this and you're
going it doesn't make sense I I just
said I thought the Celtics have the most
talented team left in the playoffs
and and then you're watching the second
half and you're going wait which team
was the eighth seed and which team was
the you know
one of the best teams in the east
hard to explain sometimes
if you just take it that next look under
the dermis is that and we've learned
this about Pat Riley as an executive for
almost 30 years now
is that he'd rather have somebody that
either one has experience or two has
something to prove
you have to have
Stars you have to have guys that are
Blue Chip and along the way he's had
several cats that have been picked
rather high but sometimes he goes gets
them from other teams too and so by
trading and using uh free agency and the
buyout Market he doesn't mind I think
what Pat has enjoyed the most and then
this entire front office with Andy
ellisburg and Adam Simon is it's the
flexibility on the roster like don't
lock yourself in all the way down to
player 17 I mean they and they worry
about the two ways now at a high level
because what they're doing is we'll
develop someone
first of all financially sound right
you're not locked into a number we'll
develop someone over
two to four years
rather than having somebody that has to
get in here and in year three if they're
not already a star and people are trying
to run you out of town and that
combination is work so when you look at
this roster yeah you still got lottery
picks like bam and uh and Tyler in the
mix but like you said I mean Jimmy was
the last pick in the first round yeah in
his draft can Tyler is there any
possibility he could play in the Eastern
Conference Finals
from a date standpoint from the press
release to the actual date he could play
in game seven but then you know it's
like
you know back in the day when used to
you know come down Avon Mountain into
the valley there in Connecticut yeah and
you're you're reaching and I'm teaching
yeah that's how it used to work baby
you're being that jab step was sick boy
you saw him you saw it they understand
how a Dayton flies
but you can't come in there trying to
get your win when you didn't play for a
couple weeks right that's true yeah
that's true and even though you know
he's a young fella and he could score on
all three levels and he you 20 points a
night you're not gonna just shove that
away I he hasn't done any dribbling or
shooting yet
um the great thing about if there is a
great thing about breaking your hand it
is that you can do other stuff but
you're doing it on a bike you're not
doing it game level I think if this team
is blessed to to head to the finals I
think that's more realistic than
if there is a game seven Great to talk
to you as always
man this is the mere fact that the Miami
Heat put me back in position I know to
get Fritz on an email yeah to get you
yeah to just dedicate yourself to
service the way that you do I do I do
yeah serve it yeah my man
uh
who's picking out the suits by the way
is that uh Craig Sager's leftovers that
you're wearing no you know better than
that uh I don't I don't spend a great
deal of money on anything other than
retirement fund uh because I'm gonna be
at Sea you understand that I am oh you
are okay Seaman yes I am a okay a man of
the sea and I'm looking forward to the
Twilight of My Life Out on the Ocean and
so I just in a boat double in a boat yes
yes
my golf game has not gotten any better
over 25 years so I turned to the ocean
now uh but I will spend some change okay
at the Haberdashery and you know better
don't you try to be no no no no you're
bringing it absolutely you're bringing
it if my listen you see where that
hairline went yeah so I might as well
keep you know my inseam tight
if the heat Advance we'll talk to you
next week I can't wait all right go back
to bed you're the best Jason Jackson Jr
III he's a Miami Heat play-by-play boys
and I don't know what's going on in that
hotel room and no lights on it was just
dark their witch projects